It's on me. I will take care of it Alex.
Wait up! What are you doing? Let's go Dutch.
No, it's my treat now.
What is the origin of going Dutch or Dutch pay, anyhow?
I heard that people in Holland tend to be very stingy, like Scrooge, in the book...
..."A Christmas Carol".
So if you go to a restaurant or pub with Dutch people,...
...they tend to pay for only their own portions.
I know it sounds very mythological,...
...but I'm wondering if the word really exists to describe such a person.
Anyhow, back to my point, since I'm used to Korean culture,..
... I don't quite understand why Westerners tend to pay for their portion only.
Even at someone's birthday party!
Once, I was invited to my Canadian friend's birthday party,...
...and after we had a nice, fancy dinner,...
...each of us had to pay for our own share.
I mean, in Korea, on such an occasion,...
...the birthday girl or boy,...
...usually buys drinks or whatever for the whole group...
...and in return gets nice birthday presents!
I see.
As far as I know, after that first round...
...the next person goes to the bar and buys another round, right?
Well, we do say "Let's go Dutch" often.
Obviously, it doesn't mean, "Let's take a plane and go to the Netherlands,"...
...it means we'll go out together but each person will pay his own share.
It's also called "Dutch treat."
I like this sort of system, since there are no obligations.
I don't like to feel as though just because someone spent...
...30 bucks on me at dinner tonight...
...that I will have to remember...
...to spend exactly 30 dollars on that person the next time we meet.